te tapes était vraiment réduit aussi
parce que ce matin nous partons du
macumba pour lier cette marie passe
partout les toboggans et nous avons fut
une course très animée le dès le début
des hommes sont sortis avec des
échappées de ce revenu après ben en fin
de course les derniers kilomètres les
échappés ont été absorbées puis est bon
mais les les costauds du classement
général salinas et est attaqué il est
parti avec aux locaux grâce et ils ont
gagné sur sept maris mais il ya un cidre
et ceux qui prétendre à la victoire
finale n'a pas perdu beaucoup de temps
il me l'a perdue que 30 secondes ce qui
fait que c'est de bon augure pour
l'avenir
dans l'ensemble on constate que la
course est vraiment contrôlé par la
pilotine oui à la pilotine
mais aussi ils ont aussi aussi les infos
de du club de louis dominicaine et c'est
pourquoi qui sont venus aussi vite sur
les échappés comment voyez-vous l'étape
de demain qui emmène les coureurs de
trinité à ducos il faut dire que le
début d'étape est d'être réduits pensons
pas que c'est mal mais nous passons pas
par le gourmand et après l'augmentation
du cos est attendue de cautionner un
circuit assez avec assez roulant gras
permettait à des baroudeurs de vollard
effet la fosse à aller chercher une
victoire d'étape et dans les unités
comme ça on peut prendre beaucoup de
minutes